allons poser la question directement à
Marie-Claude Jero qui nous attend en
direct de Montceau-les-Mines bonsoir et
merci d'être en direct sur France 3 et
lui donc ce soir face à Didier matthus
première réaction votre satisfaction
évidemment alors parler d'étiquettes
est-ce que c'est le fait de masquer plus
ou moins son étiquette qui permet de
remporter une élection en 2014
pas du tout j'ai conduit et je travaille
depuis 6 ans sur un projet municipal
j'ai une liste j'avais une liste de
policiers et de gaullistière qui était
très variés avec des compétences une
envie d'agir pour leur ville et pas du
tout une étiquette politique voilà je
l'ai dit depuis le début ça m'a été
beaucoup reproché par mon principal
adversaire mais ça prouve que les gens
nous ont les mousselines et les
monseliens nous ont entendu nous ont
compris notre projet a été local avec
des solutions au chômage avec des
solutions à l'économie avec des
solutions pour retrouver l'industrie à
Monceau qui auquel les monseliennes et
les monseliens ont adhéré